You're changing the way you're
doing locking, however. >>Right.
For the same reason a single node failing means
that we lose the entire site because of the locking.
Moving locking into something called Zookeeper,
which implements a tree system
with guaranteed order of operations on
those and with that, you build locking.
And the main advantage of Zookeeper
is that it has much higher availabilities.
If we lose a Zookeeper node, we should be
able to come back within 200 milliseconds,
as opposed to whenever somebody notices
the cache is down and replaces it.
Yes. In generally, an engineer cannot
respond at 200 milliseconds. >>Yes.
Even the best. Zookeeper is a new system,
and this is a separate system? >>Right.
Yeah. It's an Apache project, like Cassandra is.
Is there one Zookeeper box, is there
a bunch of Zookeeper boxes?
So they form an ensemble and the way it works
is there's a master and the others are sort of
read replicants and if the master fails,
it'll automatically elect a new
leader among the ensemble.
Okay. So do all the request go
to one machine? >>No.
You write to any of them so your client could
reconnect to any one of them. >>Okay.
And they automatically figure out
who to talk to. >>Cool.
Now is Zookeeper just for locking or does it do--
We're also going to be moving dynamic
configuration type stuff in the Zookeeper
and the Zookeeper provides watches on the
nodes so the apps can actually get notification
when something changes in the Zookeeper. We can
say we're going to change the add on the front page.
We just set something in Zookeeper
and all the apps update themselves.
That reminds me of one thing that was
always a challenge, and I don't know
the answer to this one already is
when we had all these app servers,
the app servers had all the configuration. A lot of
the configuration was basically part of the code.
One example would be how many memcache
boxes you have, because the memcache
library would exist on the app servers and that's
where the hashing would happen, for example.
If you're deploying a new configuration, once
you have more than a couple app servers
often deploys take time--where I think
still happen at the same time.
Right! >>And so all of a sudden, you've got half
your app servers with a different configuration.
That gets weird--let's say you're adding a new
memcache and all of a sudden you've got
half your machines accessing one set of machines
and half of the machines accessing another
set of machines, static files hashed--
like everything is weird.
Have you guys improved that at all?
>>No. That will be the Zookeeper.
Zookeeper will help? >>Yeah. You can put like what database is there and all that kind of stuff.
And the reason you don't want to just
do that in like memcache, for example,
is that you would need to fetch that
from memcache on every request
because there's no way to know that it changed.
Because memcache is--all the queries
are initiated from the apps. >>Yes.
Set this, get this--Zookeeper will actually
push that ability. >>Yes. >>That's cool.
I never look at Zookeeper, so may be it's
something I should get smart about.